[Musique]
quel est le point commun entre ces deux
objets de notre quotidien
un médicament est un smartphone et bien
c'est sur cette petite devinette que
nous allons tenter de répondre
aujourd'hui dans les quelques minutes
qui viennent alors le médicament d'abord
j'ai toujours été fasciné par cet objet
le simple fait de la vallée c'est
presque magique quelque part elle suffit
à guérir des maladies parfois braver la
mort j'ai toujours été fascinée aussi
par le fait que ce même médicament
permet de guérir des milliards de gens
tous différents vous votre voisin moi
c'est un défi de ce qu'on appelle la
médecine personnalisée comprendre
pourquoi moi quand j'ai un mal de crâne
et bien je prends un comprimé d'aspirine
et ça suffit à me soulager alors que ma
voisine de palier elle a besoin de deux
de ces mêmes comprimés pour soulager le
même mal de crâne
donc c'est ces questions sont autant de
challenge passionnant pour le futur
comprendre notre réponse personnelle au
traitement et surtout trouver le
meilleur traitement pour tout un chacun
alors je vous propose de garder en tête
ces questions qui me tiennent
particulièrement à coeur
nous y reviendrons et je vous propose de
regarder un petit peu en arrière d'abord
d'un rétroviseur
que de progrès extraordinaires ont été
réalisés en médecine depuis un siècle en
prolonge espérance de vie
on décrypte nos gènes louis pasteur
aurait cru un roman de science-fiction
s'il avait vu l'étendue de notre
biologie moderne
derrière ce médicament se cachent des
décennies de révolution technologique
est également l'autre côté bain que de
progrès extraordinaires aussi en
informatique ont été réalisés depuis une
trentaine d'années alors que des salles
entières étaient nécessaires pour
abriter un ordinateur et bien
aujourd'hui on concentre les puissances
de calcul phénoménale dans le creux de
ma main rappelons de l'âne turing alan
turing qu'on décrit comme l'inventeur
d'ordinateur pendant la seconde guerre
seconde guerre mondiale vous savez je
pense que lui aussi aurait cru un roman
de science-fiction s'il avait vu
l'étendue notre informatique moderne
eh bien ma vocation c'est de rapprocher
ces deux mondes et de pouvoir dans un
ordinateur simuler un organisme simuler
votre réponse personnelle au traitement
alors bien sûr derrière les enjeux
scientifiques technologiques
elle vient se cachent aussi des enjeux
de société savez vous que ce médicament
si innocent si familier semble-t-il est
très loin d'être anodin il ya plus de
morts chaque années dues à des
médications inadaptée que deux personnes
tuées dans les accidents de la route et
dans les suicides réunis là je pense moi
que ce petit objet un smartphone ou un
ordinateur peut t'aider à attaquer ces
problématiques et avant vous parlez
technologies et j'aimerais d'abord vous
parlez d'une petite anecdote personnelle
j'aimerais vous parler de mon épouse
caroline caroline est une fervente
militante de la cause animale
alors moi de mon côté bien dans
plusieurs années j'ai travaillé dans un
laboratoire de biologie expérimentale
sur le cancer et parmi nos activités
bien on travaillait parfois sur l'animal
vous imaginez bien la catastrophe
parfois à la maison un pas triste et sur
hem questionner at-on le droit d'user et
d'abuser parfois de l'animal est
toujours vraiment si utile que ça car
c'est un débat extrêmement complexes
entre nous et bien sûr
moi je ne renierai jamais tous les
apports de la biologie expérimentale et
de la biologie animale sur les
connaissances actuelles est néanmoins
cette discussion m'a fait me questionner
et j'aimerais partager avec vous une
partie de cette réflexion aujourd'hui
alors tiens c'est vrai c'est ce
médicament à l'origine il a été conçu à
partir de l'animal puis seulement
ensuite on l'a testé sur l'homme mais
pas sur vous en particulier
rappelez-vous nous répondons tous de
manière différente
vous moi à voisine de palier pourquoi
parceque vous madame n'aime pas la
réplique de vous monsieur et donc ses
slips quoi vous répondez différemment à
ce traitement aussi je peux me permettre
vous madame d'être encore moins la
réplique il souris de laboratoire
et donc quand en fait on attaque le
cancer par l'animal on veut guérir le
cancer avec un grand c moi je ne veux
pas guérir le cancer
non je ne veux pas guérir le cancer
je veux guérir votre cancer
facile du moins un jour ça devait vous
arrivez un jeu je vous le souhaite pas
mais si c'était le cas eh bien
j'aimerais trouver le meilleur
traitement pour vous n'est pas le même
que celui de votre voisin parce que
votre cancer ne serait pas la réplique
du cancer de votre voisin et serait
encore moins encore une fois la réplique
du cancer qu'on aurait pu provoquer
artificiellement dans un animal de
laboratoire donc est il pas une autre
manière de concevoir les choses
l'idée ici c'est de partir du patient
partir de vous de vos caractéristiques
et de les projeter dans la machine et de
créer ce qu'on appelle un jumeau digital
et dans ce jumeau digital et bien y
tester la réponse au traitement diminue
ainsi l'expérimentation animale qui est
coûteuse est questionnable éthiquement
et en plus mieux cibler la réponse au
traitement à comment y parvenir
bien sûr notre organisme est d'une
complexité extrême
un homme une femme je crois que les
femmes sont parfois particulièrement
complexe pour nous les hommes d'ailleurs
la réciproque est vraie je vous rassure
aussi et plus sérieusement bien j'aime
beaucoup
l'analogie avec l'électronique pour
appréhender cette magnifique complexité
moi je suis toujours étonné quand je
vois là le circuit d'un simple poste de
radio
toute la complexité des connexions des
sous circuit des composants et a
beaucoup d'analogies avec la complexité
de notre organisme
bien sûr en biologie peintre organismes
et d'interaction ne sont pas
électronique
elles sont chimiques elles sont
physiques elles sont biologiques et
c'est justement le la mission de la
biologie que de décrypter cette
complexité mais ya une différence
fondamentale avec l'électronique c'est
qu' aucun humain n'a conçu le schéma de
notre organisme
parce que lorsqu'un poste de radio tombe
en panne comme on connaît le schéma est
bien on sait le réparer
c'est une toute autre histoire
l'entraîneur lorsque notre organisme
tombe en panne tombe malade on ne
connaît pas de ce schéma dans un petit
peu comme si des indigènes d'amazonie
si intelligent soit il a 2 v demain on
prendra réparer un poste de radio
donc c'est encore une fois c'est le défi
de la biologie et ces dernières années
lui on arrive à comprendre de mieux en
mieux
de plus en plus de pathologies des
milliers d' équipe de chercheurs par le
monde
comme je vous ai dit décrypte cette
complexité comprennent des petits bouts
de circuit les pièces du puzzle
indépendante et c'est là qu'entre en jeu
l'informatique et les mathématiques
grâce à ces outils on va être en mesure
est bien de recoller ces petits boulots
et de faire vivre dans un monde virtuel
dans la machine des boues ces circuits
recoller des pièces de puzzle que l'on
stimule à qui on donne vie dans
l'ordinateur
ce que vous voyez ici est une cellule
virtuel une cellule cancéreuse c'est en
fait la projection du cellules
cancéreuses dans un logiciel qu'on
appelle communément une application donc
on y voit encore une fois l'analogie
avec l'électronique à tous ces circuits
ses connexions
encore une fois c'est la biologie et on
y voit toute cette complexité de la
cellule de la cellule cancéreuse qui la
rendent redoutablement efficace chaque
point
bien sûr ce ne sont pas les circuits des
points de composants électroniques
chaque point et bien c'est une
interaction biologique une protéine par
exemple on ya vu à capter race race par
exemple est une protéine qui est
impliqué dans la virulence de nombreux
cancers cancer du pancréas cancer de la
peau ce qui est particulièrement
intéressant dans cette cellule
cancéreuse virtuel un c'est que c'est
pas simplement un regroupement
d'informations
en fait derrière chaque point chaque
entité dans ce réseau va se cache une
équation est derrière un réseau entier
se cache un système d'équations à la
confluence entre les mathématiques et la
biologie
on appelle les bus aux mathématiques est
ce qu'on appelle aussi la biologie et
systèmes eh bien nous permet de mettre
en musique
ce réseau de jouer de simuler des
parties de cette cellule virtuelle des
partis et pièces de ce puzzle dans la
machine alors ça c'est un terrain de jeu
incroyable parce que cette complexité
le cerveau humain a du mal à
l'appréhender mais grâce à l'outil
informatique est l outil mathématique et
bien on est capable de la maîtrise et de
contrôler et de visualiser cette
complexité et vous savez quand on
visualise les choses eh bien on fait un
grand pas vers la résolution des
problèmes alors maintenant
mettons nous à la place d'un concepteur
de médicaments jouant le rôle du
laboratoire pharmaceutique et dans ce
jumeau digital on va pouvoir y tester
les nouveaux médicaments pour diminuer
l'expérimentation animale et favoriser
l'expérimentation sur les patients un
virtuel qui seront le reflet de votre
propre diversité oui car pourquoi pas
demain ils testaient votre propre
réponse à vos médicaments sur votre
propre avatar votre propre jumeaux
digitale n'ont pas pourrait guérir le
cancer pourrait guérir votre cancer
moi personnellement je suis persuadé que
cette innovation demain frappera notre
porte pour des médicaments dans la vie
de tous les jours et je dis ça parce que
on parle beaucoup de big data en ce
moment en biologie c'est en lien direct
avec notre sujet c'est big data ces
données massives ce sont les données qui
nous rendent tous différents qui
explique nos différences mon emploi à
mon âge ma taille mais aussi mes données
génétiques mais marqueurs biologiques
mais bio marqueurs est bon qu'ils
expliquent notre différence de réponse
au traitement et pourquoi j'ai besoin de
moins d'aspirine que ma voisine de
palier eh bien ces modèles numériques
mathématiques que je vous ai montré se
nourrissent de ces données massives ces
données biologiques c'est big data grâce
à elle on va pouvoir construire et
précisez votre avatar mettre en place
votre jumeau digital alors vous l'aurez
compris actuellement on parle beaucoup
de médecine personnalisée aujourd'hui je
vous ai parlé de modélisation
personnalisé dans un concentré de calcul
comme celui ci pour pouvoir demain y
simuler votre réponse
personnel au traitement ça c'est
vraiment le défi de la médecine
personnalisée de la médecine digital de
la médecine du futur
vous pensez peut-être que je grossis un
petit peu le trait en fait telle est ma
conviction même si peut-être aujourd'hui
pour certains mais mots résonnent comme
comme un roman de science fiction
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]